[Musik]
der neue mercedes e 500 im test wir
laden den so richtig durch als
höchstgeschwindigkeit ist bei 210 km/h
abgeregelt wir hatten 20 15 216 hoffend
akkus und extrem oft laut busse aus
tschechien die habe ich so noch nie
gesehen die sind so krass der wollte
unser reporter nicht mehr aus der terra
storm will nicht nur spielen der meint
dass er ernst und das sieht man dem auto
auf den allerersten blick an
und warum das goodwood festival of speed
und seiner reporter zum aus führten
bringt das ist eines meiner absoluten
lieblingsautos ich hatte früher ein
strand badetuch mit dem ferrari f40
drauf und jetzt stehen wir einfach
erleben wollen zusammen mein name ist
hinter hoffmann und wenn es um autos
geht habe ich so richtig die schraube
locker ich hoffe wir euch ist genauso
weil dann seid ihr richtig hier bei auto
bild das magazin wir testen für euch
supersportler elektroautos aber auch
ganz normale autos die neue auf markt
sind wir führen denn so richtig auf den
zahn und das jede woche hier bei bild tv
[Musik]